in haiti police say they've killed four
people and detained two others after a
gun battle
with suspects in the assassination of
president juvenile moise
officials say they belong to a group of
professional commandos and
foreign mercenaries who killed the
president in his home while posing as
u.s
special agents world leaders have
condemned the killing which deepens the
political crisis
in the caribbean nation the u.n security
council is due to discuss the situation
later today
this van is moving the remains of haiti
slain president jovanelle moyes from his
private residence where he was killed
outside the villa investigators scoured
for evidence and leads
as to who may have planned and carried
out the assassination
gunman raided moyes's home in the early
hours of wednesday
his wife was critically wounded and is
being treated at a hospital in florida
the government has declared an emergency
we have decided to declare a state of
siege in the entire country
i share the sorrow of the president's
we appeal to the intelligence of
haitians
in this difficult time
president moyes's assassination comes
amid rising gang violence
and a growing humanitarian crisis
food and fuel shortages as well as
rising inflation
are making life extremely difficult for
the people of haiti
one of the poorest countries in the
world
and the political situation has been far
from stable
for the past two years moysa had been
ruling haiti by decree
after the country failed to hold
elections a result of political gridlock
and unrest
the opposition called for moyesa to step
down insisting his term had
legally expired international leaders
condemned the assassination
and expressed support for haiti's
interim government
we urge haitian authorities to bring
those responsible to justice
the united states calls on all political
parties civil society groups
and stakeholders to echo what we've
heard from acting prime minister
claude joseph's call for calm and to
work together
in the wake of this tragedy and to
ensure peace
and democratic governance for now the
streets in the capital puerto prance
remain quiet
but there's a lingering fear that the
crisis could plunge haiti
into further chaos and uncertainty
you